won't believe is not vegan burgers and
that's how I found it and I started
watching hot ones sorry really hey guys
it's Greg helva here ah salsas John
Humphrey is John Humphrey
Tommy Gill it's in the gamer on twitch
oh my gosh
so John and I have had a sweaty workout
while Tony was drinking a soda when he
showed up no no Tony you're my ass thor
ragnarok and weird trailer by Aldo Jones
funny spoof parody blah blah blah you
know how this goes now Albert don't give
every reaction channel permission but
mine to watch this I just want you guys
to know that he's specifically requested
we don't acknowledge said we don't want
you and I said you Aldo I'm doing this
we said no respect god damn I don't want
watch this
[Music]
ah I switch the iPhone at home
[Applause]
[Music]
and
we won't do in here and make arrests
what is the back little girl
[Music]
Oh God that completely cut out the
opportunity watch
[Music]
no wacky hey I agree with all those
things are saying crucial to keep the
weird trail was crying long story
oh yeah I follow all these guys I'm so
familiar with that in Channel looks like
I'm fighting $5.00 to be Albert Jones so
that was you know as much as I'd love to
play that game again
Aldo it takes me way too long every time
oh thanks for pointing it out this
before having the RTS 1/2
[Music]
different ideas
this guy's misses yet I was there we go
Gasper as you spin brush
[Music]
[Applause]
I played with that guy before
[Music]
yeah yeah video serves to go viral as
soon as possible not the reaction the
actual video the reaction instead 10,000
bees probably lucky yeah I think this
video should definitely be viral I was
one of his best one
I was pretty fun that was awesome you
know of course you know all the little
inserts and all that stuff it up there
like what he does the weird trailers
that's all fantastic
I really appreciated how we did the
outro style because I remember like a
few videos ago not like the most recent
one I remember he had like a super long
outro and it wasn't like the most
entertaining type of outro but he knew
how to mix in all the promotion's the
shoutout talk about the patreon what
inserting deleted takes and I think
that's so cool because I really just
think this guy gets high because there's
not a good route to do recruiters do Oh
which one should I use you know what
I'll just throw it all on the end but I
like the way how we need through it all
da like even the editing of that was
really well done yeah man work for
guarding the galaxy 2-1 why not why not
oh yeah brother Jose Christ because
perfect is always so much fun to watch I
appreciate the the absurdity that Aldo
brings in and his you know just his
technical skills with Z are growing you
know definitely growing I mean from the
first couple of videos that you've seen
from this it was like okay you look like
placed a little couple faces in but now
he's getting so good with putting in
like the air in front of a nickel ths is
just like adds little extra things where
it's just like
so well edited yeah you know it's a
parody of course but you're just like
damn this good like I can imagine
Nicolas Cage in this room it's wiping
his spicy looks more and more flawless
as time goes on you've got the perfect
burst Campbell clip where the audio is
going along with the Led Zeppelin song
yeah yeah
is that from like ash season 2 or
something I met I think so it has to be
yeah definitely I'm never seeing that
clip before the fact of the reveal is
just that it's a haircut it was like I
got especially nice leading in the next
shot dude yeah although you've done it
again
I will pledge $5 to your patreon so I
can get my picture featured in your next
video yeah man what kind of face would
you please just go regular just simple
message on um I'm gonna yeah I'm gonna
open my mouth and eyes as wide as
possible just as just to make it so that
he has to edit my face more questions do
you pay more to get the video scenes
because you see how a couple people
donated look like they got like the
actual shooting the guns part or the guy
holding the sword like how to get those
ones that give you $10 maybe you just
gotta go to page around and find out
Tony maybes I go go to the patreon oh oh
are you saying I'm just I'm doing my put
oh yeah a little sad Greg a little thing
for the pledge why I pledge that face
yes the face I wanted a beautiful face
yeah Paul do you want us all do our Lee
or trailer face
subscribe Tony's on Instagram and he has
a twitch John Humphrey on social media
manages blunt house the whole company
and my company I built it and yep I'll
subscribe ever joke